in the village of Cardenas the men set
off for work in the morning
the women meanwhile are already hard at
work
they're busy cooking the range of dishes
bubbling away in their pots and pans is
impressive that's because in the evening
they're expecting a visitor someone
who's a great fan of their cooking
skills so what are they making herbs -
the corn to make the tamales then
there's the tomato moly sauce tamales
are a traditional Mexican dish made with
a corn dough coated with various sources
they're then wrapped and cooked in
banana leaves
Consuela Rivera Santos cooks every day
with her mother who is 93 years old you
still cook yes I enjoy cooking the women
work hard in the kitchen every day but
they receive no money for what they do
and very little recognition yet they are
the ones who decide what ends up on the
table each day which produce from the
region is used and whether or not their
families have a balanced and healthy
diet
but the women here in Cardenas are
getting help from a non-governmental
organization called Dai it promotes
traditional farming methods the NGO is
run by a single family father mother and
son have been working together for years
beyond that it only works because I
mediate between the two of them respect
is very important each of us has our own
area of expertise in the town of
Santiago al pijn are a few hours drive
away dai is hosting a local trade fair
for seeds farmers from the area are
presenting their best corn and pumpkins
the goal is to promote local crops and
traditional farming methods and also to
protect biodiversity we're showing the
rich variety of crops that are grown
here and all the different colors each
color is good for a particular dish or
drink each corn cob has its own story
and a reason why it should be grown and
each corn cob gets registered at the
fair with the farmers name the color of
the crop and how many rows of corn are
on each cob anyone who needs a
particular variety can get seeds
directly from the farmer rather than
buying them commercially that's making
it easier for farmers to diversify
strains around here for example the
black the red and the spotted corn have
started to disappear they're not being
grown as much we want to revive these
types of corn and reintegrate them back
into farming
the idea of registering each corncob
exactly is designed to encourage the
farmers to grow local varieties rather
than buying industrially produced seeds
this call was grown by a weenie Oh Gomez
he's one of the local farmers on his
land or milpa as the fields are known
here he grows pumpkins beans and above
all maize here I have yellow corn there
are 14 rows of that like to grow lots of
different colors I have four here
altogether white yellow black and red
and sometimes I've had pink spotted or
purple comunist emerado because they'd
cross propagated in the field it's a
clue simply this rich variety and the
seed so we neo gomez used to get started
we're all handed down through the family
King this type of corn here for example
has been around for a long time
my grandfather grew it and so did my
father
I like this variety I'll never stop
growing it here this eMeter corn was
first cultivated by the indigenous
peoples of Mexico thousands of years ago
despite the many alternatives available
these days most farmers here prefer to
use seeds from the region meanwhile
Lucilia Enrique's from dai has arrived
in the village of Cardenas her focus is
on the women in the region she's been
coming to the village regularly for
years
luckily gender roles are strictly
defined in this region so it's much
easier for the women here to trust
another woman and so we work together
Lucilia and the women from the village
have completed a very unusual project
they produce their own
full of their own recipes complete with
photos did the book to encourage women
to use the produce they grow in their
gardens and of course we wanted them to
be proud of their recipes each woman was
asked to contribute her favorite recipe
describing exactly how she prepares it
and which local ingredients she uses the
book was given out for free in the
village
it can also be downloaded online in the
evening the women present a small
selection of their dishes they each show
what they've been cooking today tell us
your name
Consuela Luis today I made a chicken hot
pot made from chickens that were running
around the village this morning
then there's a tallit a granny on a
local drink made from corn none of the
women here ever dreamed that they and
their recipes would one day be featured
in a book working with the NGO has
helped them realized that their recipes
made from local produce aren't just
unique but even a key to greater food
security and it's also helped many women
here to understand the importance of
their role so that they can be proud of
the work that they do each day
you